et ces intenses bombardements de l'armée
russe continue à carquif aujourd'hui le
centre de la deuxième ville du crâne est
maintenant bombardée le gouverneur de la
région l'annonce sur télégram il a
publié ses images que vous découvrez
d'une énorme explosion sur la place
centrale de la ville où se trouve le
siège de l'administration locale dans le
reste du pays l'offensive russe
s'intensifie aussi l'armée russe est
arrivée aux portes de Carson une ville
d'environ 300 000 habitants situés dans
le nord de la Crimée à Mario Paul
également cette ville portuaire très
stratégique située sur la mer d'Azov les
habitants n'ont plus d'électricité après
une offensive russe le gouverneur de la
région de doniesk assure pour l'instant
que la ville tient le coup mais la
pression est très forte je me tourne
vers vous à remettre charrier bonjour
l'offensive russe on le voit ce muscle
on a le regard bien sûr rivé sur Kiev la
capitale CARIF la deuxième ville du pays
mais aussi dans l'est de l'Ukraine
intense combat et récemment je le disais
à Mario Paul dans cette ville de l'est
de l'Ukraine très stratégique oui et on
voit comment s'opère en fait les
priorités russes on a les yeux focalisés
sur Kiev parce que c'est la capitale
parce que c'est ce qui nous surprend et
donc parce que du coup c'est vraiment le
signe de la capitulation du pouvoir si
Vladimir Poutine vient à faire tomber
Céline ski en revanche tout ce qui est
en train de se passer autour reste
capital toutes les j'avais dit à les
guerres attendues dans les républiques
séparatistes ça on les connaît mais ça
amène quand même effectivement des
guerres là où on voit qu'en plus on a
des points importants c'est surtout que
la ligne en fait que voudrais monter les
rues c'est à dire que si on part de la
Crimée et donc de Kerson là où
dernièrement on a eu effectivement des
des combats on remonte on a
effectivement aussi le port de Mario
Paul qui va être et on va jusqu'à cariff
et là si vous voulez vous avez un peu
une Ukraine que vous pourriez diviser
qui serait une Ukraine plus à l'ouest
plus occidentale et une Ukraine plus à
l'Est qui te serait plus russe est-ce
que les Russes iraient embrasé diep
forcément oui parce que ça leur donne
tout leur canal en eau potable qui
achemine vers la Crimée ça a été une de
leurs priorités et on voit pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y a des combats qui sont
importants alors la résistance
ukrainienne semble être important et
effectivement à carquif parce que c'est
aussi la deuxième ville du pays derrière
qui est et que donc du coup il se
battent tout comme on a effectivement
des combats qui sont racontés du côté de
Mario Paul et vous le disiez Mario Paul
privé d'électricité c'est quand même un
demi mignon de personnes est-ce que ça
touche toute la ville ou passe avant
c'est pas précisément mais en tout cas
on voit qu'on a des contingences très
importantes pour la population on voyait
tout à l'heure les images on va
peut-être les revoir de cette colonne de
blindée russe qui se dirige vers Kiev 60
km de long c'est impressionnant mais les
images sont rares finalement depuis ce
début de ce conflit là ce sont
pratiquement les premières images comme
ça satellitaire que l'on a dans l'est de
l'Ukraine par contre on n'a pas ce genre
d'image bien sûr c'est toute notre
difficulté pour travailler correctement
aujourd'hui on est avec des combats que
l'on sait important en Ukraine et des
images que l'on a sont assez on en a
assez peu on en a dans les villes on
arrive à vous parler de Kiev on arrive à
vous parler de Mario Paul on arrive à
vous parler de car kiff parce qu'on a
des micros images d'ailleurs c'est
souvent dès que des habitants ou des
personnes qui nous font parvenir comme
ça on voit des bombardements on a des
immeubles qui ont été éventrés la
dernière fois on a eu effectivement on
s'en était pris à un organisme du
pouvoir puisque c'était un siège
régional de gouverneur qui a été frappé
donc ça on en a on a aussi quand les
reporters vont sur place effectivement
ils peuvent raconter des images en
revanche cette colonne nous a beaucoup
intéressé parce que c'est la première
fois qu'on voyait enfin les blindés
russes là c'était 60 km au début les
questions nuageuses faisaient qu'on
disait si t'as pas 25 km et puis une
fois que les nuages sont allés on voit
davantage ce qui se passe ce qui vous
donne la difficulté du renseignement et
ce qui montre que très clairement les il
y a aussi autour des Russes et des
Ukrainiens en ce moment une guerre
informationnelle donner le moins
d'informations possibles qu'on puisse le
recouper le moins possible et tous les
spécialistes qui aujourd'hui sont en
train d'observer ce qui est en train de
se passer sont très perplexes parce que
on ne sait pas ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de l'Ukraine on a priori sur
des retours le fait qu'on pourrait avoir
des colonnes très rapides russes qui
sont en train de monter c'est
effectivement ce qu'on peut disséminer
mais en revanche on n'a rien à l'appui
ni de la part des Russes ni du segonien
et quand c'est vrai qu'on a deux armées
qui s'affrontent normalement vous avez
toujours des gens en communication qui
redonnent au moins des images et ça on
en est privé pour l'instant